Claudebot is changing the game when it
comes to AI assistance. Most AI tools
today live in a browser. You open a tab,
you ask a question, you get an answer,
and once you close that tab, everything
just kind of disappears. They're useful,
but they don't really feel like
assistants. And that's exactly the
problem Cloudbot is trying to solve.
Unlike typical AI chat bots, Claudebot
is a self-hosted AI assistant that runs
directly on your computer. It connects
to powerful AI models like claude or
chatgypt for intelligence while the
agent itself lives locally on your PC.
And this means it can actually do things
for you like write code, create files,
browse the web, and integrate with
platforms like Telegram, Slack, and
Discord. So, in this complete beginners
tutorial, I'm going to walk you through
everything that you would need to know
about Claudebot. We'll cover what makes
it special, whether you need specific
hardware, the costs involved, and most
importantly, I'll show you exactly how
to set it up step by step from getting
your API keys to having your first
conversation through Telegram. So, by
the end of this video, you are going to
have your own local AI assistant running
on your own computer, ready to help you
with your daily tasks. So, let's go
ahead and dive in and get Cloudbot set
up together. So, what exactly is
Claudebot? Most AI tools today live in a
browser. Again, you open a tab, ask a
question, get an answer, and once you
close that tab, everything just kind of
disappears. They are useful, but they
don't really feel like assistance at
all. They feel more like tools that you
have to keep reopening over and over
again. And that's exactly the problem
Claudebot is trying to solve. Claudebot
is a self-hosted AI assistant that runs
directly on your own computer. So
instead of living inside a web
interface, it just connects to dedicated
AI models like Claude or Chat GPT for
its intelligence while the agent itself
lives locally on your PC. What makes
that interesting is what it can actually
do. And Claudebot isn't just limited to
chat only. It can connect to Telegram,
Slack, Discord, Google even, and of
course other tools depending on how you
set it up. You can use it to write code,
build applications, do research, create
lists, or handle tasks that you would
normally bounce between multiple labs
for. Because it's running locally,
everything stays on your machine. Your
conversations, your files, your context,
none of that is sitting on some random
third-party server. And that's the real
advantage here. So, with the right
configuration, Cloudbot feels way less
like a typical AI chatbot and a lot more
like an actual assistant that
understands your workflow and can
interact with your computer. You can
have it help build full projects, manage
research, or automate things in the
background all while chatting with it
through Telegram or whatever platform
that you prefer. So, what are the main
features of Cloudbot? When people hear
AI assistant, they usually imagine
something that understands their
workflow and helps behind the scenes.
[music] In reality, a lot of the tools
stop at conversation and don't go much
further than that. Once you start using
Clawbot, though, it will be very much
obvious that it's more than just a
chatbot. It's designed to actually do
things for you and not just respond to
prompts. At a basic level, Claudebot can
execute commands directly on your
computer. It can create files, write
code, and even browse the web if you've
configured it properly. And that opens
the door to automating tasks and
handling real work instead of just
getting text responses. [music]
It also integrates with messaging
platforms like Telegram and Slack and
Discord. So, you're not locked in to a
single interface. You can talk to it
from the tools you already use every
day, which makes it feel a lot more
natural to work with. One of the more
powerful features is memory. Claudebot
can remember past conversations and your
preferences over time. So, the more that
you use it, the better it starts to
understand how you work and what you
usually need help with. On top of that,
there's a web dashboard that gives you a
full view of your chat history, the bot
status, and all of your settings. So you
don't need to dig through config files
unless you actually want to. Everything
important is visible in one place.
Cloudbot also supports multiple AI
models. So if you have API keys for both
cloud and chat GBT, you can just switch
between them depending on what you need
at the moment, which is great if you
prefer one model for certain tasks over
another. And finally, file creation is a
big one here. Cloudbot can generate
documents, spreadsheets, and
presentations and other files too,
directly from your requests without you
having to open a single application. Do
you need a Mac Mini or a Mac device? A
question that comes up a lot is whether
you need a Mac Mini or even a Mac at all
to run Cloudbot. And the short answer is
nope. You can run Claudebot or Multibbot
on pretty much any modern device,
whether you're on a Mac, Windows, or
Linux even. There's no special hardware
requirements and no need to dedicate a
machine just for this. It also doesn't
use a ton of system resources because
you're not running a full language model
locally. Claudebot just connects to
existing AI models from providers like
Anthropic or OpenAI. So your computer is
mainly just running the agent itself.
Are there costs involved? So when it
comes to cost, Cloudbot itself is
completely free all to use. You're not
paying for the software or the agent.
What you do need though is an API key
from an AI provider like Anthropic or
OpenAI. And that is where any cost comes
from. How much you end up paying really
does depend on how often you use it and
which model you choose as your default.
More powerful or newer models of course
will cost more per request, but they
also tend to give better results. So
there is a trade-off there. Lower tier
models are cheaper, but the experience
can feel a bit more limited. On top of
that, some of Cloudbot's advanced
features really do rely on additional
thirdparty services, which means extra
API keys and potentially extra cost. So,
while Cloudbot itself is free, the total
cost can vary quite a bit depending on
how you configure it and how heavily you
use it. So, how difficult is it to set
up Cloudbot? So, let's be real here. The
setup isn't completely plugandplay.
Sorry. Especially if you're not used to
working with the terminal or dealing
with API keys. There are a few moving
parts and it can feel a bit intimidating
at first. You'll need to install things
like Node.js, add your API keys, and set
up whichever messaging platform you want
to use, like creating a Telegram bot.
Some of that involves running terminal
commands and in a few cases editing JSON
files, which can be unfamiliar territory
if you're not a developer. The good
news, though, is that once everything is
configured properly, Cloudbot runs very
smoothly, and you rarely need to touch
the settings again. It's mostly just a
one-time setup. The documentation
definitely helps, but you may still run
into a few bugs or some rough edges
along the way, especially around API
keys and gateway tokens. But if you're
comfortable following guides and using
basic terminal commands, well, you
should be able to get everything up and
running in about 30 to 60 minutes. The
hardest part here is usually just
getting all the keys set up correctly
and making sure your messaging platform
connects properly. So, before we install
anything, we do need to decide which AI
model Claudebot is going to use. To do
that, we'll need an API key from an AI
provider. I'm going to use Claude, but
you can follow the same process with
other supported providers if you do
prefer. Claudebot supports multiple
providers. So, if you'd rather use, say,
OpenAI instead, you can just grab an API
key from OpenAI and follow along with
that. And if you're going with Claude,
then head over to platform.claw.com
and choose the option to get an API key.
From here, you'll be asked to give the
key a name. And once it's created, all
you got to do is just copy it. We'll be
pasting this into Cloudbot during the
setup in the next step. Now that we've
got our API key, the next step is
actually just installing Claudebot. And
the process itself is pretty
straightforward. On the CloudBot website
here, you'll see a single line install
command. Just copy that, open up your
terminal, and paste it in. Once you run
it, the installation will start
automatically. And at this point, you
just let it do its thing. If Node.js JS
or Git isn't already installed on your
system, the installer will take care of
that for you. In my case here, I already
had everything set up since I am a bit
of a developing developer, if you could
say that. So, it's really just
installing CloudBot itself. And once
that's done, you just wait for the
installation to finish before moving on
to the configuration steps. Once the
installation finishes, Claudebot will
automatically jump straight into the
configuration process. Here, you don't
have to manually start anything. It just
picks up right where the install leaves
off. Early on, you'll see a prompt that
says something along the lines of, "I
understand this is powerful and
inherently risky. Continue." So, go
ahead and say yes here so you can move
forward with the setup. Next, you'll be
asked to choose an onboarding mode. So,
for this setup in this video, go with
quick start. It's the fastest and the
easiest option and lets you get
everything up and running without having
to tweak a bunch of settings right away.
After that, you're going to be asked to
choose your AI provider. This is where
you decide which model Claudebot will
use for its intelligence. Since we
grabbed a Claude API key earlier, I'm
going to select Anthropic here. Just
keep in mind this isn't a permanent
decision. You can use any supported
provider that you want and it really
comes down to personal preference. After
selecting Enthropic, choose Enthropic
API key and paste in the key you copied
earlier. After that's set, Cladbot will
ask you to pick a default model. There
are quite a few models available, so
this part is really about balance. In my
case, I went with Sonnet 4.0 because
it's efficient and still has a fairly
recent knowledge base. More powerful or
newer models will generally give better
results, but they will also burn through
your credits a lot faster, and that's
something to keep in mind here. The good
thing is you're not locked into this
choice. You can always switch models
later if you just want to. Just be aware
that each model has its own personality,
so to speak. So, if you change it down
the line, the responses might be a
little different. So, after that initial
setup in the terminal, the next step is
moving the conversation over to
Telegram. Open up the Telegram bot that
we just created and send the
forward/start command to kick things
off. After a short moment, Claudebot
should respond, letting you know that
the connection is working and that it's
ready to chat with you. Once you see
that message, you're officially talking
to your own local AI through Telegram.
And from here, you can start having real
conversations with it. I'm going to ask
it a few questions, bring up some
general topics, and then give it more
information about myself and what I do.
And you can see that it responds
properly and keeps the context of the
conversation. This part is actually
pretty important because the more you
talk to Claudebot and give it context
about how you work, the better it gets
at understanding you. And just like with
training AI models, giving it more
information over time helps it build
better memory and respond in a way that
fits your workflow. Also, let's go into
the Claudebot dashboard here where you
can see the chat history showing up in
real time. Now, that's a good way to
confirm that everything is connected
correctly and that's all working as
expected. After setting everything up
and chatting with Cloudbot just for a
little bit, you might start wondering,
huh, what else can it actually do? Well,
Telegram is a great starting point, but
it's really just the beginning here.
Cloudbot isn't limited to Telegram only.
It can also integrate with other
platforms like Slack, Discord, and
additional messaging tools. You just
need to configure them in the settings.
Once set up, you can interact with the
same local AI from multiple places. It
can also interact directly with your
computer. Cloudbot can run bash
commands, create files, and help
automate tasks, which makes it
especially useful for things like
coding, file management, or repetitive
workflows. So, if you connect a web
search provider like say Brave Search,
Cloudbot can pull in up-to-date
information from the web instead of
relying only on its training data.
That's really useful when you need
current information or just some quick
research. Memory is another big part of
how Cloudbot works. It remembers past
conversations and can reference them
later. So, the more you do actually talk
to it, the better it understands your
preferences and how you work. On top of
all of that, it can also write and run
code directly. Why not? Of course,
[music] generate documents,
spreadsheets, presentations, and manage
files, all from chat. You can ask it to
create reports, organize your data, or
draft documents without opening any
other apps. You can also customize how
Cloudbot behaves, what it calls itself,
and how it responds. So, it does feel
more tailored to your workflow instead
of a generic assistant. Also, there's a
built-in web dashboard at localhost
col18789
where you can see your full chat
history, monitor the bot status, and
manage settings without ever touching
configuration files. And finally,
everything is privacy focused. Because
CloudBot runs locally on your machine
only and connects directly to the AI
provers API, there's no routing your
conversations through third-party
servers. At the end of the day,
Claudebot is basically your own local AI
powerhouse. Something that you can talk
to from your phone or your desktop, but
that actually lives on your machine and
works the way you want it to. And that's
pretty much it. That's CloudBot in a
nutshell. It's a local AI assistant that
actually works with you, not just talks
to you. We focused on the core setup
here so you can get up and running
without over complicating things. But
there is a lot more you can build on top
of this once you are comfortable. Thanks
for watching and investing your time
with me today. I'll see you at the next
one.